it's only an hour and a bits drive from
jerusalem down to gaza
through an israeli checkpoint which they
have now opened after 11 days
and with multiple vehicle changes it is
a journey
into a different world well we're in
the ceasefire is exactly 12 hours old
and for the moment
it's holding the damage of the past two
weeks of bombings is quickly clear
and so too is the relief of the people
here they can finally emerge into
streets
which are safe no one here knows why
this building was hit
a residential block in the neighborhood
of bet hanoon
but inside celebrating eid last week
were two families
among them bilal miriam yamin
yusuf and in the middle maria
ten people are now dead they were all
women and children
nearby awake the ceasefire has allowed
for people to gather
to mourn
maria survived that night with her
father ala abu hatib
they are the only two from the family
still alive
for public
[Music]
the israeli military insists that this
wasn't them they say a hamas rocket fell
short and that in time they will prove
it
but then no hamas rockets which have hit
israel have caused anything like this
damage
we move on through the narrow streets
passed more wakes for a meeting with a
hamas official
dr basim naim is a surgeon by training
but speaks for hamas
and defends its actions any people under
occupation based on the international
law have the
all the right to defend themselves by
all
feasible means they have not by firing
rockets from a civilian population
i have said it clearly palestinians as
an occupied people have the right to
defend themselves
by all feasible means including our
resistance but when it comes
to civilians we have said that many
times we are ready to stop
firing rockets or attacking civilians if
this really stop
attacking our people would you sit down
with an israeli to talk this through
why to sit with him my my demands are
clear
i don't i don't need to sit with him we
have achieved a lot without sitting with
each other
back in beit hanoon more friends of the
abu hatibs offer their support
one family just two people now but a
pain
shared mark stone sky news in gaza